dans dix ans tintin aura atteint l'âge
symbolique de 77 ans lui qui est né le
10 janvier 1929 de la plume et du
pinceau de georges remi sera ce la fin
d'un règne universel qui n'a
d'équivalent qu'en celui de mickey la
souris inventé par disney bien sûr que
non bien que très inscrite dans
l'histoire de leur temps les aventures
de tintin et milou
tout comme les trois mousquetaires ou
les misérables sont assurés de durée
à quoi tient cette pérennité assurée
s'interroge pierre assouline dans la
rigoureuse biographie d'hergé qu'il
publie chez plon et comment l'enfant des
termes beck née en 1907 dans un univers
morose
bon élève et prix de dessin et de
scoutisme at il pu inventer un style la
ligne claire grâce auquel il s'impose au
monde entier au point qu'un steven
spielberg et puis souhaitez acquérir les
droits de l'ensemble de ses volumes
allez expliquer le génie qui différencie
hergé de ses collaborateurs doux et
edgar p jacobs ou bob de moor pire
assouline ne t'ai rien et il fait oeuvre
novatrice des compromissions douteuses
auquel hergé s'est livré pendant la
guerre avec les nazis belge et qui la
mèneront un temps à penser s'exiler en
argentine
hergé était toute à son oeuvre 23 albums
hors pairs parés du beau nom de
classiques